Today, we know and track virtually nothing
that’s happening in our own brains.
But in a future that is coming
much faster than you realize,
all of that is about to change.
We're now familiar with sensors
in our smart watches to our rings,
that track everything from our heartbeats
to our footsteps, breaths,
body temperature, even our sleep.
Now, consumer neurotech devices
are being sold worldwide
to enable us to track
our own brain activity.
As companies from Meta to Microsoft,
Snap and even Apple
begin to embed brain sensors
in our everyday devices
like our earbuds, headphones, headbands,
watches and even wearable tattoos,
we're reaching an inflection point
in brain transparency.
And those are just some
of the company names we're familiar with.
There are so many more.
Consumer neurotech devices
are moving from niche products
with limited applications
to becoming the way in which we'll learn
about our own brain activity,
our controller for virtual reality
and augmented reality.
And one of the primary ways we'll interact
with all of the rest of our technology.
Even conservative estimates
of the neurotech industry
put it at more than
38 billion dollars by 2032.
This new category of technology
presents unprecedented possibility,
both good and bad.
Consider how our physical health
and well-being are increasing
while neurological disease
and suffering continue to rise.
55 million people around the world
are struggling with dementia,
with more than 60 to 70 percent of them
suffering from Alzheimer's disease.
Nearly a billion people struggle
with mental health
and drug use disorders.
Depression affects more than 300 million.
Consumer neurotech devices
could finally enable us
to treat our brain health and wellness
as seriously as we treat
the rest of our physical well-being.
But making our brains
transparent to others
also introduces extraordinary risks.
Which is why, before
it's too late to do so,
we must change the basic terms
of service for neurotechnology
in favour of individual rights.
I say this not just as a law professor
who believes in the power of law,
nor just a philosopher
trying to flesh out norms,
but as a mother who's been personally
and profoundly impacted
by the use of neurotechnology
in my own life.
On Mother's Day in 2017,
as my daughter Calista
lay cradled in my arms,
she took one last beautiful breath.
After a prolonged hospitalization,
complications following infections
claimed her life.
The harrowing trauma that she endured
and we witnessed stretched into weeks.
And I was left with lasting trauma
that progressed into
post-traumatic stress disorder.
Sleep escaped me for years.
As each time I closed my eyes,
I relived everything,
from the first moments that I was pushed
out of the emergency room
to her gut-wrenching cries.
Ultimately, it was the help
of a talented psychologist,
using exposure therapy,
and my use of neurofeedback
that enabled me to sleep
through the night.
For others who are suffering
from traumatic memories,
an innovative new approach
using decoded neurofeedback,
or DecNef, may offer reprieve.
This groundbreaking approach
uses machine-learning algorithms
to identify specific
brain-activity patterns,
including those associated
with traumatic memories.
Participants then play a game
that enables them
to retrain their brain activity
on positive associations instead.
If I had had DecNef
available to me at the time,
I might have overcome my PTSD more quickly
without having to relive every sound,
terror and smell in order to do so.
I'm not the only one.
Sarah described herself as being
at the end of her life,
no longer in a life worth living,
because of her severe
and intractable depression.
Then, using implanted brain sensors
that reset her brain activity
like a pacemaker for the brain,
Sarah reclaimed her will to live.
While implanted neurotechnology advances
have been extraordinary,
it's the everyday brain sensors
that are embedded
in our ordinary technology
that I believe will impact
the majority of our lives.
Like the one third of adults
and nearly one quarter of children
who are living with epilepsy
for whom conventional
anti-seizure medications fail.
Now, researchers from Israel to Spain
have developed brain sensors
using the power of AI
in pattern recognition
and consumer electroencephalography
to enable the detection
of epileptic seizures minutes
to up to an hour before they occur,
sending potentially life-saving alerts
to a mobile device.
Regular use of brain sensors
could even enable us
to detect the earliest stages
of the most aggressive forms
of brain tumors, like glioblastoma,
where early detection
is crucial to saving lives.
The same could hold true
for Parkinson's disease, to Alzheimer's,
traumatic brain injury, ADHD,
and even depression.
We may even change our brains
for the better.
The brain training game industry,
worth a staggering
6.5 billion dollars in 2021,
was for years met with controversy
because of unsupported scientific
claims about their efficacy.
But now some brain-training platforms
like Cognizant have proven powerful
in improving brain processing speeds,
memory, reasoning
and even executive functioning
when played repeatedly over time.
When paired with neurofeedback devices
for learning reinforcement,
this could revolutionize
how we learn and adapt to change.
Other breakthroughs
could be transformational
for the human experience.
Today, most human brain studies
are based on a very small
number of participants
engaged in very specific tasks
in a controlled laboratory environment.
With widespread use of brain sensors,
the data we could have to learn
about the human brain
would exponentially increase.
With sufficiently large datasets
of long-term, real-world data
from people engaged in everyday activity,
we just might address everything
from neurological disease and suffering
to creating transformational possibilities
for the human experience.
But all of this will only be possible
if people can confidently
share their brain data
without fear that it will be
misused against them.
You see, the brain data
that will be collected
and generated by these devices
won't be collected in traditional
laboratory environments
or in clinical research studies
run by physicians and scientists.
Instead, it will be the sellers
of these new devices,
the very companies who've been
commodifying our personal data for years.
Which is why we can't go into this new era
naive about the risks
or complacent about the challenges
that the collection and sharing
our brain data will pose.
Scientific hurdles can
and will be addressed in time,
but the social hurdles
will be the most challenging.
Unlike the technologies of the past
that track and hack the human brain,
brain sensors provide direct access
to the part of ourselves
that we hold back,
that we don't express
through our words and our actions.
Brain data in many instances
will be more sensitive
than the personal data of the past,
because it reflects our feelings,
our mental states, our emotions,
our preferences, our desires,
even our very thoughts.
I would never have wanted
the data that was collected
as I worked through the trauma
of my personal loss
to have been commodified,
shared and analyzed by others.
These aren't just hypothetical risks.
Take Entertek, a Hangzhou-based company,
who has collected millions of instances
of brain activity data
as people have engaged
in mind-controlled car racing,
sleeping, working,
even using neurofeedback
with their devices.
They've already entered
into partnerships with other companies
to share and analyze that data.
Unless people have individual control
over their brain data,
it will be used
for microtargeting or worse,
instead of treating dementia.
Like the employees worldwide
who've already been subject
to brain surveillance in the workplace
to track their attention and fatigue,
to governments,
developing brain biometrics,
to authenticate people at borders,
to interrogate criminal suspects' brains
and even weapons that are being crafted
to disable and disorient the human brain.
Brain wearables will have not only read
but write capabilities,
creating risks that our brains
can be hacked, manipulated,
and even subject to targeted attacks.
We must act quickly to safeguard
against the very real
and terrifying risks
to our innermost selves.
Recognizing a human right
to cognitive liberty
would offer those safeguards.
Cognitive liberty is a right
from interference by others,
but it is also a right
to self-determination
over our brains and mental experiences
to enable human flourishing.
To achieve this,
we need to recognize
three interrelated human rights
and update our understanding of them
to secure to us a right to mental privacy,
to safeguard us from interference
with our automatic reactions,
our emotions and our thoughts.
Freedom of thought
as an absolute human right
to protect us from interception,
manipulation and punishment
of our thoughts.
And self-determination
to secure self-ownership over our brains
and mental experiences,
to access and change them
if we want to do so.
There are important efforts
already underway
from the UN to UNESCO,
in nations worldwide,
over rights and regulations
around neurotechnologies.
But those rights need to be better aligned
with a broader set of digital rights.
Cognitive liberty is an update
to liberty in the digital age
as an umbrella concept
of human flourishing
across digital technologies.
Because the right way forward
isn't through metaverse rights
or AI rights
or neurotech rights and the like.
It's to recognize that these technologies
don't exist in silos,
but in combination, affecting
our brains and mental experiences.
We are literally at a moment before.
And I mean a moment.
Consumer brain wearables
have already arrived,
and the commodification
of our brains has already begun.
It's now just a question of scale.
We haven't yet passed the inflection point
where most of our brains can be directly
accessed and changed by others.
But it is about to happen,
giving us a final moment to make a change
so that we don't look back
in a few years' time
and lament the world we've left behind.
We can and should be hopeful
and deliberate
about the choices we make now
to secure a right to self-determination
over our brains and mental experiences.
The possibilities, if we do so,
are limited only by our imagination.
Thank you.
(Applause)